you know what's going on guys this is
statistically challenged again sorry
I've been uploaded for a week but we are
back today I've got a really interesting
video for you guys I thought it'd the
idea a couple days ago and finally
gotten around to actually recording it
we're back at the GE again gonna be
another flippin video we're gonna be
flipping the alphabet today now you
might be asking what the hell does
flipping the alphabet mean you're gonna
flip an item that covers every letter of
the alphabet so by the end of this video
we're going to have done 26 flips I'm
gonna be starting with a hundred mil
cash you don't need this much to
actually flip in the game so if you're
discouraged to start flipping because
you don't have this much money don't be
I'm just using it because it's a nice
round even number now to help me while
flipping I'm going to be using GE
tracker if you guys want to check out
this website they're a partner that the
channel go check the link in the
description I'm gonna be using the
highest margins flips just to kind of
guide me towards which items will make
us the most profit as you can see I can
alphabetically order them here by
clicking the item tab and now they are
all in alphabetical order and I'm just
gonna look for the ones that have a nice
high margin and we're gonna try to slay
every single letter in the alphabet and
see how much profit we can make and I'm
gonna start with this one right here
look at that eternal glory
quarter of a mil if we can just flip it
we just get it free quarter of a mil
right there I'm not gonna have a time
around this video guys I'm just going to
casually try to flip 27 items this might
be recorded over a couple days but yeah
at the end of the day we're gonna see
how much we can make and I will give you
an estimate of how much time actually
spent on the game doing it yeah anyways
I'm gonna walk the first item in here
for 21.18 know how much the eternal
glory is buying for right now we have
eight slots so we can put in eight
letters right away let's go to letter B
Bandos or an amid kit 400 K margin I'm
obviously gonna cut the margin of it
because I want to finish this video by
the end of the year okay I'm gonna put
it in for three point one no in 55 K all
right so the best item starting with the
letter C right now is called a clue box
this has a 5.8 K March band first of all
what the hell even is this item whatever
we're gonna put it in for 18 point 3 K
on to the letter D dark tuxedo shoes
quarter of a mil margin I don't even
know what half of these items gonna slap
it in for 630 K alright allies and
spirit shield is the best one for the
letter e but I mean spark match so we're
gonna go with the evil chicken feet at
the United to K margin alright we've got
three more spots left
rousers though for 18k is their best one
one grand exchange spot left the options
for the letter H not too hot as well
seems like I'm gonna have to go with the
holy sandals those they have almost a
10km urgent just gonna check back in a
couple hours and log off guys yeah I'm
gonna catch you guys back then alright
so we've just logged back in it's been
about twelve hours I guess now before I
actually went to bed I quickly logged on
and the holy sandals and clue box did
buy I flipped both of them successfully
as you guys can see because I put them
back in for sell offers we got an 8k
margin on the sandals and about a 6k
margin on the clue box which isn't too
bad but we also bought three items now
three of them unfortunately didn't buy
I'm not really too surprised because
these are very very uncommon like clue
items but I'm just gonna go ahead and
collect what we did buy now this eternal
glory is gonna be an easy profit of like
200k gonna put it in 420 10.35 we bought
it for 21.18 and it is already being
actively traded between a twenty one
point three and twenty one point four
mil I'm gonna be patient with the gilded
boots evil chicken feed to the Manos
godsword
I'm gonna start adding the next two
letters in we have to do the letter i'
and then the letter j I think I'm just
gonna stay safe and I'm gonna go with
the imbued heart solid 50k margin today
we actually instantly bought it at two
point five five mil and the eternal
glory just sold there's 200k profit
right there look at that a nice eternal
glory margin alright so I'm not seeing
any items recommended with the letter J
it skips from hiding so we're gonna have
to do some improvising here boys this
thing can go anywhere from around 2000
GP to 7k so what I'm gonna do is stick
it in for 2.5 there you go there is the
imbued heart flip I told you guys this
was gonna be like an easy 40 K profit
right there you guys can see let's get
the letters K and the letters L in here
I'm gonna hold tight on the ones that
didn't buyout alright guys so it hasn't
been that long spin a couple hours and
back in a lot of our stuff is green in
the grand exchange which I'd love to see
we actually got the Jade machete for
only two point five thousand GP sold off
the flare trousers
got a free 15 K margin off that and we
also sold the dark tuxedo shoes guys for
we bought them for 630 K 230 K margin
just like that bought dollar rupiah had
Andy Carroll's top these are not buying
whatsoever so I'm just gonna abort these
for now so we still need the letter BG
and even take care of those first before
I move on it still seems that the band
of Scott's work it is the best margin so
you know what I'm just not gonna give up
on this one and yeah so you can see the
price is a little higher than what I was
buying it for we're just pretty much why
we could never buy it in the first place
all right and for the letter E the elder
model is showing up at the best market
in 33k right there I'm not gonna do an
Ellie because I don't have that kind of
cash and there we go now we're gonna
take care of the items we bought for
these two slots we're gonna be doing new
letters m and n only option for the
letter n is actually the necklace of
anguish which has a 10-point 8k margin
so item is traded like a hundred plus
times an hour so this should be a very
fast flip but we just insta-buck the
necklace spanglish 12 mil 57k we should
be able to easily get this for twelve
know and like 68k yeah guys we're just
gonna leave all these in and come back
again only spend about like ten minutes
doing all that so yeah it's been about
30 minutes we log back in band Oh Scott
sword kit finally bought sold Olivia had
finally Andy Carol stop all right for
the letter O obsidian armor set at a 50k
margin looks at very promising
primordial crystal has a 266 K marking
this is actually traded enough times an
hour that this could be a pretty fast
flip so we're gonna get on this right
now you put it in for nineteen point
four three mil and if we can sell this
for 19 point six five plus will be an
easy 200 K margin another full G you
guys I will be right back when I log
back in okay we're back it's been about
an hour um a lot of sold actually we got
the necklace of anguish flip easy the
band Oh Scott sword ornament kit finally
sold so that gets us rid of the letters
ed and beef and we bought the granite
boots we're gonna try to sell these as
fast as we can and try 341 K on D and
the next letter is Q I can't even think
off the top of my head an item NR s that
starts with the letter Q okay guys I
think we have a problem there is an item
in the game that starts with the letter
Q literally
things you know to be honest I'm not
complaining that's another letter out of
the way let's move on to the next one
which is the letter R ring a nature 190
margin put the letter s another godsword
ornament kit 99 K profit you know I'll
do it alright this is probably gonna be
the last check-in for today but guys
look what just happened I just came back
it was like 25 minutes and look how much
stuff we just bought and sold it's gonna
collect all of it right now put all the
items I just bought back in we actually
instantly just sold the Eldar mall there
everything is in and I'm probably gonna
check back in tomorrow so yeah pretty
nice though a lot of stuff unsold one of
the best feelings coming back to a full
G of everything being sold we got a lot
of good flips in here yeah we're just
gonna go ahead and collect collect on
that also gonna put sell offers in for
the saradomin God's or an ornament kit
and the monk rope Jeep kind of a long
shot here I'm gonna put this one in for
a 1.53 Mel but the toxic staff uncharged
here I'll 102k margin that's [__] nice
the next one is a weird one the letter U
for the letter U we're gonna go with the
unholy blessing has that 11 K margin
popping in for about 170 7.5 k right
there not too many good options for the
letter and fee
looks like the bear RAC helm is the best
we'll get with the 9.1 k margin alright
the wooden shield G isn't rated much at
all this is for the letter W we've only
got like four options here I'm trying to
get that 40 K margin the only items
starting with the letter AK are the
isaiah szura shin pieces i don't even
know how you pronounce that
well i think we're gonna have to settle
with the anelia not
with d12 GP margin absolute [__] back
another full GE I'm probably gonna log
off and come back later to check what
it's sold on but alright it is pretty
late right now just log back in to come
to a full GE of green bars or no one got
to an ornament kit the monk robe cheap
that's gonna remove the letters SM an X
to do is sell off at these five item and
finish off with the letter said alright
so a pretty easy decision
the zamorak spear has a 143 came Arjun
and now all we have to do is put sell
offers on all of these five items as I
was commentating at the exam
axé beard came say they were going but
they sell offer in and now I'm just
gonna go to bed and hopefully tomorrow
morning is when I can finish the video
alright guys so it is the next day and
everything has actually sold which is
really really nice I'm gonna go ahead
and click that collect and there you
guys have it that is the alphabet
flipped in the GE remember that we
started with an even 100 mill so when I
go ahead and examine the coin stack here
we made one point for eight mill now
this took me a couple of days but an
actual gameplay time I was probably on
for about just an hour
I was probably on for about just an hour
if not less and that I'm literally
consisted of me just putting in GE
offers and pretty much collecting stuff
but yeah nonetheless still very fun
challenge glad we were able to complete
it
yeah it's guy looks like a proper
[__] scrub I mean look at that
defense a me iron longsword or something
bronze plate legs means the cash that's
all I'm saying
oh my god I haven't seen full bronze in
ages
come back yo that bronze it looks so
[__] cool I honestly hope that helps
man you look like you could need the
cash she's gonna plug in the youtube
link and should answer this question so
yeah it's basically gonna conclude the
video guys if you made it this far tell
me in the comments you should write the
vid that subscribe if you want to see
more and check out my other bits if you
like ones like this because they do have
a lot more that was flipping the ABCs on
the GE but yeah I have nothing more to
say so until next time guys however good